Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sambha sambuddhasa homage to the buddha the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one so i just picked up on a discourse and it's concerned with how we discuss things with each other how we talk to each other so in this age of great polarization i thought well let's see what the buddha has to say
it comes from the Anguttanikā which is a collection of the small discourses and it starts off like this there are mendicants these three topics of discussion what three you might discuss the past this is how it was in the past you might discuss the future this is how it will be in the future and you might discuss the present
this is how it is at present now at first that seems a bit sort of obvious but of course there are three very different conversations the first one is all about memory and about opinions about memory and what we thought had happened the second one is all driven to some sort of future idea some idealism
and there could be arguments about that and the present of course is sort of an attempt to see things as they are but everybody sees things differently so there's all sorts of argumentation so what the discourse does is it takes the process of discussion the first one is the skill in questions
so you can see whether it's worth talking to somebody here they would say a person is the discourse says a person is competent to hold a discussion but what it means is whether it's worth you talking to them and remember that at that time when you read the discourses they didn't have recording machines remember so
the way that you got people to be clear was to ask the question three times and to make sure that is is that what you mean and it was done either as two individuals or in a group so that the position taken was clear what was said was clear and that would undermine silly arguments and at that time they had a sort of
imagination which is called reproductive imagination not like ours you know if if you see a car crash you'll see it one way and then you won't be sure that you've seen it because you didn't record it fully and there'll be there'll be questions asked in those times they had what was called reproductive memory
imagination and they were very good at remembering things even today at the 1956 sixth great council held in Burma there were six monks who knew all the scriptures all the Abhidhamma and all the Vinaya the rule of the monks I mean that's a massive amount of literature they knew it off by heart
and when the questions came about certain passages in the scriptures which were maybe not quite right or whatever it was these people these monks who became the experts who would quote from directly from the scriptures okay so oh just as an aside by the way it seems that the Brahmins
they teach their children the scriptures and learn them by heart and they're concerned with pronunciation only when they can learn that do they actually add the meaning of the words and only when they've got the words and the pronunciation together are they allowed to discuss what the scriptures say okay so here are the sorts of questions that somebody can ask
So when a person is asked a question, if it needs to be answered categorically and they don't answer it categorically, then that shows they're not worth talking to.
So one of the things that you might say in Buddhism is, is the Buddha impermanent?
And if they prevaricate, yes, no, maybe and all that, then what we want is a clear statement.
Yes, yes, it is.
another one is is uk a european country now i should say yes lots of uk people don't think they are i think but but but that's what should be said at least geographically now the next sort of question might need analysis so one regular question is is buddhism a religion so then you have to ask well what do you mean by religion right
Another one is when the Buddha is describing this whole idea of not-self, he starts off with control.
How much of the body can you control?
Is it under your control?
Can you make it grow taller, etc.?
So then you'd have to say, well, when he means control, he obviously means the body as an organism.
But obviously I can move it around.
I do have some ability to control it.
and of course what he's really pointing to is sickness aging and death yeah now sometimes you ask a question it needs a counter question so one dharma question would be are the ear and nose the same so you say well in what way you say well in their function well yes they are they're the same they both perceive these days of course we have this
all think about immigration.
So a question might be, should immigration be allowed to stay?
Well, then you say, well, what are the types of immigrants that are coming to the country?
And can we make distinctions?
As a teacher, you see, a vipassana teacher.
So I might say to you, how's your practice going?
And you say, oh, yeah, that's good.
Now, if I'm a bad teacher, I'll say, oh, very good.
I'll take your word for it.
but if i'm a good teacher then i'll say well in what way you say and you say well my mind is more quiet i'm able to see process more clearly i say sad and sad if you say to me well i'm feeling a lot happier i said no it's not about happiness that's the end product and then uh there are questions that should be set aside so in a in a conversation somebody might ask you a personal question so you don't have to answer that you know even if it seems to be relevant
now in the buddhist teachings there were 10 questions that he wouldn't answer they are known as the avyagata they are the undeclared 10 statements or questions so first of all they they run like this is the world eternal is the world not eternal is the world finite or is the world infinite so that he wouldn't answer i mean i don't think he'd know frankly
although I have to say in the commentary on the Visuddhimagga it does unfortunately say that the Buddha knew the world was flat so this he didn't say anything about the world as something objective out there his main interest was the world that we are creating moment after moment the next one is is the soul the same as the body
is the bowl is the soul one thing and the body another now he doesn't answer that and it's something that i think is worth investigating on another little talk so i won't go into the uh into that particular one and then finally there were four questions around atatagata remember that's how he referred to himself the one who had arrived who had gone who had um yeah who had completed the path
and it refers to any arahat really so does a tatagata exist after death does he not exist after death this is known as the quadrilemma does a tatagata both exist and not exist after death and here's a headbanger does a tataga neither exist nor not exist after death well not surprisingly he didn't make an answer to that
uh the real reason of course was that people were thinking of the tatagata or a liberated one as a person as a self so he just he didn't like those sorts of questions he didn't like any questions that were speculative basically so now we move on to a different section which is the skill in the conventions of conversation so when a person is asked a question if they're not consistent about their position
or what their position is and what it isn't about what they propose and then they change the subject about speaking from what they know and not from some sort of fake position and that it's appropriate to the procedure so this is really when you're having a discussion with somebody you're not speaking over each other and
politicians are very good at that.
I was watching a BBC interview with Varoufakoulis, Varoufakoulis, I think that's his name, the Greek economist, some of you may know.
And there was an economic lecturer there.
She was from some Oxford or somewhere.
And of course the interviewer.
And at first there was, he was asking the questions, they were answering it all, looked very civilised.
And then right at the end, the three of them spoke all together.
trying to trying to crush the other it's just weird and of course i didn't get a word of it so when a person is asked the question if they're consistent about their position what their position is and what it isn't about what they propose about speaking from what they know and about the appropriate procedure then that person is competent to hold a discussion
how people engage the next session how people engage when being attacked so you can know whether or not a person is competent to hold a discussion by seeing how they take part in a discussion when a person is asked a question if they dodge the issue distract the discussion with irrelevant points display annoyance hate and bitterness then that person is not competent to hold a discussion so
So that's politicians, isn't it?
Dodging the issue, distracting it, saying something irrelevant and occasionally sort of getting a little bit uppity about things.
So when a person is asked the question, if they don't dodge the issue, distract the discussion with irrelevant points or display annoyance, hate and bitterness, then that person, you know, we can talk to them.
The next question is how people engage with confrontation.
So afraid of being bettered.
So you can know whether a person is competent to hold a discussion by seeing how they take part in a discussion.
When a person is asked a question, if they intimidate, crush, mock and seize at trivial mistakes, then they're not competent to hold a discussion.
In other words, don't talk to them.
but when a when a when a person is asked a question if they don't intimidate you crush you mock you seize upon trivial mistakes then it's worth talking to them and it's all often in conversation it's about winning not not about finding some sort of truth not about finding some sort of way of compromise uh not even even coming to a position of agreeing to differ it's about who wins
I saw really quite a horrible discussion on YouTube between a university professor and Jordan Peterson.
And somebody whom you'll know, I just can't bring his name to mind, but it was vicious.
It was about woke.
And the professor especially was very insulting, you know.
But, yeah, what can you do?
I think the other two, Jordan Peterson and the other fellow, I mean, Jordan Peterson, you know, is a right wing guru.
And the other fellow was on the left.
If I was any of those, I'd have just walked out.
You're just insulting.
OK, so now we have a general disposition.
You can know whether or not a person has what's required by seeing how they take part in a discussion.
If they actively listen, they have what's required.
and if they know what they're talking about well actually this the next section is about the Four Noble Truths but there the Buddha is actually stressing the fact the ability to listen you know not to be afraid of actually what the person might say be open to the fact that your own position may be changed may be nuanced often when we enter into a discussion about something
There's an underlying fear of being changed, of losing.
So the next one is much more to do with the scriptures.
It says, for someone,
who has what's required, directly knows one thing, completely understands one thing, gives up one thing and realizes one thing.
That one thing, of course, is nibbana and the path to nibbana.
And here the Buddha points out that the purpose of all discussion, as far as he's concerned, and consultation, sitting close and listening well, is the liberation of the mind by not clinging, by not grasping.
so finally there's a sort of coda those who converse with hostility too short of themselves arrogant ignoble attacking virtues they look for flaws in each other they rejoice together when their opponent speaks poorly makes a mistake becomes confused and is defeated but the noble ones don't discuss like this
If an astute person wants to hold a discussion connected with the teaching and its meaning, the kind of discussion that the noble ones hold, then that wise one should start the discussion.
Knowing when the time is right, neither hostile nor arrogant, not over-excited, contemptuous or aggressive, or with a mind full of jealousy, they speak from what they rightly know.
they agree with what is well spoken see you know actually praising the per the the other the person who has a contradictory idea praising them or at least accepting when they've made a decent argument without criticizing what has been poorly said they don't persist in finding faults nor seizing on trivial mistakes nor intimidating nor crushing the other
nor would they speak suggestively snyderly good people consult for the sake of knowledge and clarity right that's a really good statement good people consult for the sake of knowledge and clarity that's how the noble ones consult this is noble consultation knowing this a wise person should control without arrogance
So that's the final section of the discourse.
And remember, we shouldn't take these discourses as sort of final statements about these things.
Even subjects like dependent origination crop up in various discourses from various angles.
So it's not as though we take a discourse and say, well, that's everything to be said about discussion.
Far from it.
They're just pointers.
and our task is to translate what we have understood back into our own lives and of course into society especially these days when as we when as you know there's so much polarization um the body himself you know when somebody reported to him what one of his monks on or nuns had said he would say well if you'd have asked me that question i would have said the same thing
okay so now just before we finish off i just want to point to two three books and i'll put them on the website the first one is i don't know whether you can see it is um non-violent community uh communication you can see that guy just a minute there we go and um oops what have i done ah uh by uh rosenberg
and uh that that is really a very famous book and definitely worth reading about how to talk to people and the other one i've not read it entirely but i read little sections of it it's called difficult conversations oops just a minute it's because of the uh it's because of the oi that's it and uh it takes up little difficult difficult conference why is it doing that i wonder oh yeah
difficult conversation all right i shall leave it like that finally i don't think you'll be able to get this book but you might do it's called bad arguments and uh it tells you all the silly all the ways that people sort of don't answer your question don't converse with you in a proper manner and just cause confusion and anger usually so very good
I hope this little discourse is of some use to you in your life and in society and is just part and parcel of your path to complete and full liberation from suffering sooner rather than later.